let's talk about the l word today no not
that L word the other L word liberal
I've always considered myself a liberal
probably before I even knew what the
word actually meant as a kid I remember
thinking that liberals were the good
guys
liberals were looking out for other
people liberals wanted a fairer society
and liberals didn't care about race or
religion before I go any further you
guys know I love definitions so let's
actually define the word liberal
according to the oxford dictionary one
open to new behavior or opinions and
willing to discard traditional values
too concerned mainly with broadening a
person's general knowledge and
experience rather than with technical or
professional training all right being
open to new opinions and broadening your
knowledge both seem like good ideas
right with these two definitions in mind
you can understand why liberals have
been on the forefront of the civil
rights movement workers rights women's
rights and marriage equality sometimes
to get everyone to a place of equality
you have to throw out the societal norms
and be willing to accept a new normal
conservatives often argue that change
isn't good or at least change that comes
to fast ISM I think in certain cases
there can be some truth to that
mentality but if you're the black person
sitting in the back of the bus or a
woman trying to vote or the gay person
who can't get married change can't
happen soon enough I mention all this
because I don't want to lose my cred as
a real liberal since I've had some
conservative guests on the Rubin report
I've seen people suddenly calling me or
conservative or claiming that I'm a
Republican as I've mentioned before I've
never voted for a Republican for any
major office so if I'm a Republican I'm
a pretty bad one just because I talked
to Ben Shapiro or Milo you nah police or
your own Brooke of the iron Rand
Institute doesn't mean I share any or
all of their beliefs and that's exactly
the same as when I talk to left-leaning
guests like Jimmy Dore Arriva Martin or
my guest this week John Fugelsang I
listen to people push back when I see
fit and see where the conversation goes
I know some of you want me to
electrocute my guests every time they
say something i diss
agree with but there is a litany of
legal reasons we just can't do that
but beyond the legal reasons I'm a firm
believer that good ideas always beat out
bad ideas if you let the light shine on
both of them it's not liberal or even
decent to shout down or silence ideas
just because you don't like them that
has been and always will be the driving
force behind the Rubin report
I view liberal thinking and liberal
ideas is generally good over the past
few months as I've explored classical
liberalism with its focus on civil
liberties and economic freedom I've come
to realize in many cases liberal ideas
aren't that far from libertarian ideas
you can make excellent arguments for
racial equality gender equality and
marriage equality all from both liberal
and libertarian points of view the main
difference is how you think the role of
government should be applied in any of
those cases a liberal may want marriage
equality because they believe that a gay
couple deserves to be treated the same
as a straight couple a libertarian may
want marriage equality because they
don't believe the government has the
right to tell any two people what kind
of contract they can partake in the
silent majority of us have much more in
common than we have a part especially if
you're a moderate on either side or just
a good old-fashioned centrist I tend to
think that most of you who watch the
Rubin report fall somewhere on that
spectrum I don't pretend to have every
answer because it's preposterous to do
so unfortunately not having an answer
doesn't stop most Talking Heads I prefer
to analyze each situation with the same
level of critical thinking that I apply
to the rest of my life unfortunately
many liberals have taken a turn into
stifling dissent with cries of racism
and bigotry every time they hear an idea
that they don't like to me being liberal
is a constant evolution of ideas as time
goes on this concept doesn't mean
changing my ideals or my morals from day
to day but it means that I can change as
the world changes I see the world in
shades of gray rather than black and
white the world is constantly changing
and I'm not ashamed to admit that my
opinions have changed along with it
isn't the position of a man without
conviction it's a position of a man with
a conscience as liberals we must be
brave enough to have our ideas
challenged just like we challenge the
ideas that came before us at the end of
the day this isn't about right and wrong
it's about having the bravery to defend
your ideals
so to my liberal friends who have chosen
censorship over ideas and smearing over
debate I challenge you to be brave if
our ideas are good and our cause is just
we shouldn't be afraid to defend them
you